these are the remains of what were once
happy Homes apartments blown up in the
latest round of airstrikes they're just
amoebas no other way to call them
bastards this separisha man says several
people were injured at least one died in
a war many Russians remain steadfastly
against
using actions that hold potentially
deadly repercussions
tell me why you're taking me says this
woman detained by police
Kremlin has made descent illegal
punishment reportedly now includes
military enlistment in operation
underway around the country that's
facing Fierce resistance
this unverified video shows a fight as
men are forced onto buses some asking
why police don't have to fight in the
trenches
meanwhile as rebel-held regions of
eastern Ukraine hold votes to redraw the
borders some are actually being cast
from within Russia I hope we'll become
Russians for real says this man who fled
to Russia the votes backed by the
Kremlin are carried out by puppet
governments they're called a sham by the
West who predicts a predetermined
outcome absolutely Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski telling his Nation
the pseudo referenda will be condemned
we cannot be passive when big Powers
flout the rules
the war has dominated the UN General
Assembly and on Saturday
China's foreign minister called for a
peaceful resolution that respects both
sides comments that ensure the nation
doesn't endanger its strategic
relationship with Russia but is a signal
that even Russian support has limits
Reggie Global News